[Music]
tomorrow marks 90 years since the world
first met Mickey Mouse it didn't take
long for Walt Disney's creation to
become a star appearing in dozens of
films and television shows and serving
as the icon of the Disney Corporation
and to mark his 90th birthday Sotheby's
is auctioning off this collection of
rare posters from Mickey's heyday of the
1930s and 40s so we're talking some of
the rarest animation posters in the
world and animation is one of the best
and most collected genres with Mickey
Mouse being the most celebrated
character the collection on display now
in London includes a poster celebrating
Mickey's 8th birthday believed to be the
only one in existence that's also the
case for this French silly symphony
poster they could each sell for about
$30,000 bidding on this Belgian poster
for Fantasia starts at $1700 but the
prize of the collection is this poster
dating back to the early 1930s it was
likely displayed in a movie theater and
is just one of two known in existence
he's looking pretty good 490 all yeah